real boys please
moisture one soup I used to feel like I
have no talent I used to feel like the
only thing I knew was the streets but
now for like I can rap my name is in
leve I am a school counselor here at the
new visions charter high school for
advanced math and science - this is a
space within my counseling office where
students come to write and record tracks
about different emotional experiences
that they've had music is therapy so he
just created a space where kids can come
talk about their problems talk about
specific problems they have and transfer
all that energy and some music
especially hip-hop music once you step
in the office is just a whole different
vibe you have other people who are
thinking as hard as you are about the
craft and like they can exchange other
concepts that you would have never
thought about and then you could also
apply your writing and record and make
something though
I represent the colors of youth I
colored the booth where every syllable
that comes out from under my tooth I
thunderous prove to why I'm always
Rumble the truth the path to riches
always they are more we send the pursuit
I learned from miss Olivia if you can
put all your thoughts and emotions and
just one song and you can you can try to
rap with it like just go ahead and do it
best when I write on that I'm serving up
a pot full of coffee on my ground French
immigrants French I used to be really
shy I've learned how to be more open
with myself as a person I got more
comfortable I'm talking I'm making
friends and I'm speaking all that
through my rap I come into the classroom
and I automatically start rapping I can
really express my feelings here like I
could act like myself I definitely
understand myself it's not really about
school I mean it is about school because
we're in school but like it's about life
and working towards building something
for yourself that you love and enjoy and
this is helping you to understand who
you are and how you feel